una hora en el salón oval de la Casa
Blanca estuvo Kevin y Joe biden en su
segundo encuentro en menos de dos
semanas para tratar de llegar a este
este acuerdo para aumentar el límite de
la deuda en Estados Unidos al final de
la reunión dijo que se podía llegar
incluso a un acuerdo final de la semana
que estaban avanzando en la negociación
pero que todavía había mucho por acordar
así entonces las dos partes tanto El
Ejecutivo como el legislativo en este
momento en manos de los republicanos
designaron un equipo negociador que
según Fuentes cercanas esta misma noche
empezarían las negociaciones para poder
llegar a este acuerdo que según se
necesitaría llegar para que Estados
Unidos no se quede sin plata para poder
atender las deudas que tiene y pues eh
una cantidad de programas y el mismo a
flote de el gobierno y de su presupuesto
para mantener el país y las finanzas del
país
Qué hace que las posturas de los
republicanos y los demócratas sigan tan
alejadas que incluso llevaron al
presidente a cancelar su segunda parte
de la gira por Asia prevista luego de la
reunión del g7
exactamente el presidente Valle no irá a
Australia o a Japón recordará su viaje y
lo que tienen de diferente los
republicanos y los demócratas en este
caso es que los republicanos están
usando de alguna forma este límite de la
deuda para decirle al gobierno que tiene
que recortar los gastos recortar los
gastos en en educación en financiar la
deuda estudiantil y recortar los gastos
en el programa que tiene el gobierno de
Joe biden para financiar la energía
verde lo que dice el gobierno de esquí
es necesario seguir adelante con esos
programas y que no va a generar el
déficit que dicen los republicanos
generará tanto gasto es de Resaltar que
lo que tienen mucho miedo tanto
republicanos como demócratas y por eso
están empujando las dos partes para
llegar a un acuerdo es que en caso de
que se llegue precisamente a este
desacuerdo y no se y empiece el
incumplimiento de pagos el pues esto
llevaría entre otras cosas a que muchos
accionistas vendan sus acciones haya lo
que dicen acá de acciones en Wall Street
y pues se cree de alguna forma un pánico
financiero además pues Estados Unidos
poder acceder a crédito teniendo en
cuenta este alto riesgo que significa el
incumplimiento de los pagos Sería mucho
más costoso para el país y Por ende para
el consumidor y el productor
estadouniden